initially we wanted to talk about Tucker
Carlson facing threats of EU sanctions
because we have confirmed statements
from these uh parliamentary members in
the EU literally threatening Tucker
Carlson over his interview with Vladimir
Putin but then I realize the gravity of
some of these tweets you've got this
tweet from Wanita brck with 12,000
retweets 31,000 likes and 3.8 million
views followed by a quote tweet from cat
turd with 1.7 million views and 15,000
retweets wiita brck brck says this POS
dictator zinsky has put Tucker Carlson
on a kill list for interviewing Putin
Biden has helped him with your tax
dollars this is incorrect okay cat turd
says this should disqualify this corrupt
POS from getting another dime from our
country now the challenge here is it's a
massively viral story that is half wrong
half right no no no Ukrainian government
official according to the fact check has
placed Tucker Carson Tucker Carlson on
this list in fact this website has had
Tucker Carlson on the list going back to
August so he wasn't just placed on it
and it wasn't because of the interview
with Vladimir Putin now to be fair W de
Brer did not say because uh or actually
no she literally did say for
interviewing interviewing Putin it
appears that there is another entry
placed because of uh following his
interview with Putin now it's not a kill
list it's a propaganda directory of some
sort a resource for pro Ukraine
individuals and the reason why I say
it's kind of Hal true is the fact
Checkers are trying to claim it's not a
kill list it's literally not but it kind
of is you know what I mean if you're a
high-profile individual and you appear
on this list they are basically saying
to anybody who might have access to you
you are a bad person who is working
against them and of course it has been
reported that many people who do appear
on the list do have been killed you know
and and I don't know how many what the
ratio is but I do certainly think it was
important to to start with this because
it's gone it's gone a little little bit
crazy on social media that being said I
want to highlight something that uh you
know I thought I had this pulled up but
now it's gone totally lost come on Ian
with your cans and it's all taking a sip
for that one absolutely yeah what
happened to this story that we had
pulled it's just gone it's literally
gone so you've got NBC News oh perhaps
it's right here uh we got it we got it
we got it there we go NBC news last
March Iowa police investigated a bomb
threat targeting a junior high school
they determined that the threat was a
hoax but a detective from the police
department had a theory about its
possible inspiration the libs of Tik Tac
account here's here's why I want to put
these stories together okay Tucker
Carlson has been on a list since August
he has another entry addit to the list
it appears I could be wrong it could be
the same it looks different following
his interview with Vladimir Putin he
certainly is under a heightened security
threat it's probably getting death
threats these fact Checkers on the
community notes say it's not a kill list
it's not a kill list the corporate press
then claims Libs of Tik Tock the same
day today is inspiring bomb threats by
targeting individuals so it's funny how
when it comes to the perceived enemies
of the establishment no no no you know I
should say yeah they're they're not
being threatened they're not a kilist
but when it comes to someone reporting
on and sharing information which does
create a threat to the establishment
they say you are inspiring death and
killis they call it stochastic terrorism
this is a t tactic of the left where
they accuse the right when the right
says hey I am critical of your thing
they call it stochastic terrorism then
when Tucker Carlson is placed in the
crosshairs they say no it's totally fine
they're just saying you know he's A's
he's a propagandist but the outrage is
crazy I don't know what you guys think
of uh the corporate press so far and
their entertaining posts about Tucker
Carlson and Vladimir Putin it's complete
hysteric isn't it it's kind of wild uh I
mean it's these confusing articles that
come out where they're saying Tucker
Carlson says he's the only one who's
tried to interview him you'll get a
quote from an AP reporter being like he
does he really think he's the only one
who wants to talk to Putin and at the
same time they're sort of condemning him
for talking to Putin you you have to say
what do you guys want did you guys want
to have the exclusive or are you mad
that he's doing this well how about this
any country that we have given hundreds
of billions of dollars to I don't think
we should be in a debate over the
semantics of whether or not it's a kill
list or it's some you know government
hit list and it happens to be that
Americans who have ended up on that list
have have been basically killed um by
the Ukrainian government and I think
people don't understand the lengths to
which the regime has gone to cover up uh
what is going on in Ukraine and I think
why you're seeing these crazy numbers in
some ways I think it's sort of the The
Strand effect as as cliche as that may
sound but look they don't want Tucker
Carlson to interview Putin I would say
look no further than the fact that it
was less than a week after Russia
invaded Ukraine back in February that
the Pentagon again they never publicly
announced it but they I believe it was
The Intercept through through Foya uh
got documents showing that they
established the or reestablished the
influence and perception management
office which they basically used to
spread basically misinformation and
disinformation they say counter
misinformation and disinformation not
just abroad but domestically here at
home too and that's why I think you see
them in freef Fall because they've had
such a monopoly on trying particularly
to control this narrative not just
because Ukraine works as part of their
their broader Global agenda but I think
on a personnel and personal level when
you talk about you know the Biden
familes involvement there I think
Ukraine has just sort of been a cash cow
for a lot of DC Elites so I think that's
why you're seeing such a a mad rush to
really keep what's going on there under
WS so the website my understanding is
not official uh is not affiliated with
the government officially but has worked
with law enforcement sources in Ukraine
and uh uh foreign government sources for
verification of you know information or
whatever so it's kind of just like the
fact Checkers here well but I I would
say say this is this is clearly a a uh
uh information Warfare uh asset for them
listing all these people and showing all
this propaganda things like this and uh
uh the government uses contractors it it
would be absurd to be like oh no they're
not CIA they're just a contractor for
the CIA they're a totally private entity
they're not associated with the
government the president's not involved
they just sometimes coordinate you know
what I mean we pay the bills on occasion
but have there have there been American
citizens who were who were on this list
and killed I I believe there were or I
don't know if it was necessarily this
list but I think the whole Gonzalo lra
case I'm pretty sure he was I'd have to
imagine he's he's been on their list and
then they hunted him down and now he's
he's reportedly dead you know uh my
point is we shouldn't even be in a space
where there's gray area about whether or
not it's like a kill it regardless or if
Americans are dead or alive like for a
country that we have given so much money
to but it's not a government website so
it's but it's but I think it more or Le
I think that's like saying the
factchecking organizations here in the
United States that have been set up as
sort of outfits of federally funded
institutions or they're receiving
federal funds it's like well I guess
they're technically not but I think
that's precisely the point they like to
be able to play that kind of shell game
say oh well it's technically not the
government but by all intents and
purposes it is it is acting in the
interest of the government probably has
some kind of you know intermediary it's
fascism it's fascism man it's why it's
so uh so hard to combat because you
can't really see it a lot of times
especially in the age of
corporatism I just love how they're
they're like it's not a kill list okay
just some people on it have been killed
there is a difference but there is a
difference that's true but it's kind of
like yo they're putting crosshairs over
to should be this specific if we're
going to go line by line on whether it's
a kill list or like a Target list how
about we audit all the billions that we
have sent to Ukraine with that same
level of a fine tooth comb but these
people don't actually care about
semantics know where that money went
exactly they're never going to audit it
yeah no for real like wasn't it wasn't
it reported like half the money no they
actually do not know where it is this is
gone and the the best part too speaking
speaking of how the mainstream media has
continuously Run cover on this narrative
I believe it was back in October of last
year um it was not leaked but they had
were talking with Politico from the
Biden White House saying that the new
narrative that they wanted on the
Ukraine war was that our Aid packages
over there were actually a boon to the
United States economy it was great for
the manufacturing base it was great for
jobs just the most bogus BS narrative
you've ever heard but a month two months
later you can look back at some of the
stories all these media Outlets are Ed
running with this narrative basically
saying oh Ukraine contracts oh it's
great for you know the Eon it's great
for the defense contractors yeah I guess
it's great for the Beltway but this was
even down to like local newspapers and
like affiliate stations pumping this
very fake narrative that was
disseminating directly from the White
House if you traced it from what they
were saying in political all the way to
these newspapers so they've obviously
have been working overtime um to to
Really create this and and I think too
it's really interesting there's this
entity in DC called the US
Ukraine Business Council it's sort of
like a lobbying group um but again they
play a little bit of semantics where
they say technically we're not
registered for in lobbyists but they're
hosting meetings all the time with
defense contractors but they have
Sitting members of Congress including
Democratic representative Marcy capter
listed as one of their strategic
advisers so there really is this I think
I maybe like Chinese door is that's the
wrong country sort of a good way to put
it but when you're dealing with Ukraine
I think especially now that they're that
they're at War it's like there really is
no meaningful difference I think between
what the country is doing when they're
sort of tangentially related to the
government and it not being a direct
asset of the government but frankly even
I'm sure you guys remember how FTX was
partnered I believe it was with the
ministry of digital transformation in
Ukraine that story like even if you want
to go down the route of going down
specific Ukrainian government entities
that have been caught up in corruption
there are I would say dozens of of those
avenues that you could pursue too but
the media is never going to do that so
they're just going to going to play word
semantics with like killis vers not try
to kind of strawman or I guess maybe
they're still trying to Rebrand Ukraine
as a sympathetic country that is
Justified in in getting billions of
American dollar a sympathetic country
like Ukraine would not be capable of
having a kill list because they're
democracy right if Ukraine loses like
they are the Bastion of democracy it is
kind of funny that Ukraine is literally
the opposite of
democracy yeah they'll just kill you if
you're in the way they're suspending the
elections yeah hey when the Washington
Post said democracy dies in darkness it
wasn't a warning they were telling you
their playbook that's what they want to
do thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net